locals and tourists alike taking full
advantage of las vegas being 100 percent
open again
it's clear business is booming but when
can we expect a full recovery
orco mana joining us live near the strip
tonight orco has that answer
well brian we're seeing it everywhere we
go crowds of people gambling in the
casinos
here on the las vegas strip and
partygoers filling fremont street
las vegas is back but experts say it'll
still take about 12 months for our
economy
to fully recover step inside this bakery
on west charleston and it's like a trip
back in time completing the 1950s feel a
dial telephone pastel cookware and
vintage decor
it's a blessing joe schlesinger owned
starburst parlor and bakes these keto
friendly creations she hopes to open her
store
soon but this wasn't always part of her
plan
i was a general manager for 11 years on
the strip
and then when pandemic hit it all ended
like many schlesinger started from
scratch due to the covet 19 shutdown but
she's looking forward to a business boom
now that las vegas is fully reopened
again vegas coming back is the best
thing that could ever happen to our city
crowds are now coming to town but when
will our economy actually see the
results of this rebound
we still have some work to do to get
back to something we would say is a
pre-clogged 19 norm analyst jeremy
aguero tells me
that'll take about one year partly
because reopening businesses are dealing
with hiring and supply chain problems
there is no bad part of the fact that
our economy is reopening let me be clear
about that
but there are challenges that come with
the speed at which we're reopening
aguero expects the issues to be
short-lived and schlesinger is ready to
serve up
some tasty treats i can't wait to open
my doors and welcome them into my new
home
aguero also says that a full rebound
here will also depend on conventions
coming back to las vegas
he says that international travelers
tend to stay in vegas longer
and business travelers tend to spend
more money reporting live near the las
vegas strip tonight orco mana 8 news now